You've said that a marriage must be
based on trust and transparency and
being shackled together.
How and for how long should you get to
know someone?
How does set a foundation?
Oh,
well,
you know there's no.
There's no simple answer to that.
Hello.
I think that you should know someone
well enough so that you can so that you
know if you can negotiate with them and
so that you have started to formulate a
vision of your joint future that you can
both look forward to with enthusiasm and
confidence.
So and of course that's going to depend
to some degree on your level of
maturity,
but that means you've considered such
things as do you have a sufficient
number of joint interests and are you
oriented in the same direction with
regards to how you're going to handle
your joint careers and the possibility
of children and that the manner in which
you're going to interact with your in
laws and you have to start thinking
about.
You have to start considering your life
together.
From the perspective of practicality and
economics,
I would say so.
It can't just be that massive erotic
attraction that's associated with with
love,
although I think that's extraordinarily
important and you're unbelievably
fortunate if you have that and you
should do everything you can to maintain
it.